getting to breaking news out of the UK
on the Tory leadership raise the leader
to be the all the race to be the leader
of the Conservative Party in hence the
next prime minister Theresa May and
Andrea Ledson have progressed to the
final run of Michael go the Justice
Secretary has been eliminated from the
UK Tory leadership contest it was a
contest of three Michael Gove received
46 votes in the contest May received 199
votes and misled 'some received 84 votes
Theresa May the Home Secretary of course
the longest-serving Home Secretary for
over a century she was the victor in the
first round after the first round only
on Tuesday of course we had Steven crab
drop out and the former defense
secretary Liam Fox he came last crab
dropped out and they both threw their
support behind Theresa May if you looked
at the bookmakers on Zorn odds checker
before today it was assumed at least
according to those who were laying bets
that Theresa May who you could see here
and Andrea Ledson would prevail and
vaani it has proven so so what happens
now it goes to the party members of the
Conservative Party those members across
the country the grassroots supporters
there are roughly 150,000 so the two
females the remaining candidates will
put their put their case to the
membership of the Conservative Party
there's Andrea led some and we should
have a leader it's been said by sep
tember the ninth so not only will we
have a leader of the Conservative Party
on sep tember the ninth we will have a
prime minister as well some members of
the Conservative Party body are pushing
for the process to be quickened because
of course this this race was hastened by
the elimination of crab and elimination
of the former defense secretary I was
just talking about but it's an all
female race to be the next prime
minister